en el último vídeo resolvimos un
problema en el cual esencialmente
teníamos que resolver cuánto valían los
lados de un triángulo pero en lugar de
utilizar el teorema de pitágoras no lo
utilizamos porque no teníamos un
triángulo rectángulo y lo que hicimos
fue básicamente buscar la manera usando
el soca tohá y lo que obtuvimos fue la
respuesta correcta en efecto así que lo
que te quiero introducir hoy es algo
llamado la ley de los cosenos que fue lo
que esencialmente probamos en el vídeo
pasado ahora quiero mostrarte una vez
que ya sepas la ley de los cosenos lo
cual podrás aplicar a todo tipo de
problemas como el que hicimos en el
vídeo pasado y bueno de hecho lo
resolverán más rápido yo no soy fan de
memorizar las cosas pero si tienes tu
habilidad de comenzar a memorizar las
funciones trigonométricas hazlo seguro
seguro estarás listo para probar
cualquier otra identidad si ya sabes eso
sí lo tiene memorizado así que bueno
vamos a dar inicio con esto veamos de
qué trata esta ley de los costes de la
que te vengo mencionando entonces
digamos que yo conozco que yo conozco
este ángulo este ángulo es teta y
llamemos a este lado
pero mejor no hay que llamarle bueno de
hecho de jan y sería muy bueno de hecho
mantener el mismo color de los lados así
que voy a poner aquí morado este a esto
llamémosle
a este lado ce y bueno finalmente ahora
si hay que llamar a este lado a ahora
bien si esto fuera un triángulo
rectángulo podríamos usar el teorema de
pitágoras de alguna manera pero ahora
pues no podemos no podemos porque
entonces qué hacemos qué hacemos se me
ocurre vamos a asumir que conocemos el
lado b conocemos el lado c y conocemos
también la teta y queremos ver cuánto
vale a pero en general mientras tú sepas
tres de estos tú podrás obtener el valor
del cuarto así que qué podemos hacer
cómo le hacemos lo haremos exactamente
igual como lo hicimos en el último
problema así que yo dibujo aquí una
línea de hecho me salió muy mal así que
ok
pensé que usando la herramienta de línea
aquí está entonces dejó caer aquí una
línea una línea perpendicular así que
bueno que tenemos ya tenemos dos
triángulos rectángulos con aquí están
sus ángulos rectos este es un ángulo
recto este es otro ángulo recto ya
podemos utilizar funciones
trigonométricas teorema de pitágoras
etcétera etcétera entonces bueno cuánto
vale
este lado de aquí uso otro color de
hecho quizás meta muchos colores pero es
por tu propio viento confía en este lado
púrpura cuánto vale veamos a éste si
usáramos el soca tohá vamos a usar su
carta de hecho entonces escribo acá
arriba son acá
tohá han estado púrpura es el cateto
adyacente cierto aja el adyacente de 30
mientras que esta es la hipotenusa de
este de este triángulo rectángulo ajá
entonces bueno sabemos que yo voy a
derecho ya dejar de usar colores porque
me tomará toda la vida si sigo cambiando
colores así que bueno sabemos que el
coste no detectan pondré de hecho aquí
nombres y llamemos a este lado el lado
el lado de del lado de a la letra d me
refiero sabemos que el coche no de teta
es igual a d sobre b d sobre la
hipotenusa cierto b o sabemos también
que d
es igual a
desigual ave porque se no detecta cierto
ver por coseno dt está ahora llamemos a
este lado a este lado llamémosle
este lado ese y quien ese es todo este
lado menos es cierto
de hecho entonces entonces bueno lo voy
a escribir acá
es igual hace menos de y acabamos de ver
quién es de entonces el lado él es igual
a c - b por coseno de teta b coseno de
teta eso es a eso es igual y aquí está y
ahora cuánto vale esta línea de color
rosa llamémosle a este lado el lado
m m ok bueno m es opuesto de está cierto
y ya sabemos quién es pero también
sabemos quién es ben b es muy es un lado
muy sencillo ves la hipotenusa entonces
qué relación nos da m sobre b o lo que
es lo mismo cateto opuesto sobre
hipotenusa es el sol el seno opuesto
sobre hipotenusa entonces sabemos que m
sobre b es igual a seno de teta entonces
lo voy a escribir acá m sobre b es igual
a seno de tetas seno de teta y m es
igual a b por seno de teta baja
simplemente multiplico ambos lados de la
primera ecuación por b entonces que
llevamos hasta ahora conocemos m
conocemos y queremos averiguar quién
está y aquí aquí está el truco conocemos
dos lados de un triángulo rectángulo
queremos saber cuánto vale la hipotenusa
podemos usar el teorema de pitágoras
saja y el teorema de pitágoras nos dice
que
al cuadrado es igual a m al cuadrado más
al cuadrado cierto ajá entonces bueno
pero que es m al cuadrado más sea al
cuadrado creo que sí siempre voy a
cambiar de color así que al cuadrado es
igual a m al cuadrado donde me es igual
a b c no detecta entonces vecino de teta
al cuadrado más al cuadrado donde
sabemos que vale menos veco seno de teta
entonces se me nos ve coste no detecta
esto al cuadrado porque tenemos que al
cuadrado y ahora hagamos álgebra
entonces bueno esto es igual a b al
cuadrado por seno cuadrado de teta donde
s no cuadra de 3 lo mismo que ese no
detecta el cuadrado más desarrollamos
este binomio al cuadrado entonces
tenemos sea al cuadrado
- dos por c por b por coste no detecta
más de cuadrada por cocino de teta y
simplemente hice este desarrollo ahora
veamos si podemos hacer algo interesante
si tomamos este término y este término
entonces éste y éste ok
esto es igual esto es igual de cuadrada
por seno cuadrado de teta más b cuadrada
por coseno cuadrado de teta de hecho
aquí es un 2 esto es al cuadrado
entonces cuadrado detentan más se
cuadrada más se cuadrada menos 2 por b
por c por coste no detentan y bueno
viene que a quien simplifica esto esto
es igual
esto es casi no tengo espacio esto es
igual a b cuadrada por seno cuadrado de
teta más coseno cuadrado de teta de
hecho aquí algo ya se te debe ocurrir lo
ves no sé si lo veas pero bueno más se
cuadrado menos dos por b porsche por
coste no de teta y éstos en un cuadrado
de temas coseno cuadrado de eso es igual
a 1
así que esa es una identidad con la que
trabajamos al inicio de todo esto se
consigue jugando con el teorema de
pitágoras por tanto esto vale 1 y nos
quedan regreso a mi color original
entonces bueno ya casi lo tenemos ya
casi ya casi tenemos que al cuadrado es
igual a este término se hace uno
entonces tenemos de cuadrada más
se cuadrada más se cuadrada menos
por b por c x coseno de teta teta
elegante no crees a mí me parece bueno a
esto se le llama la ley de los cosenos
es muy útil porque si conoces un ángulo
y dos lados de cualquier triángulo
puedes resolver para el tercer lado el
lado que falta guau eso es genial así
que bueno o si conoces tres lados de un
triángulo puedes entonces conocer
cualquier ángulo eso también es muy muy
útil y la única razón por la que por la
que bueno dudo o bueno si tú estás
viendo trigonometría en estos momentos
en clase o tienes un examen
si memoriza sexto bueno es bueno
memorizar esto porque te darán agilidad
y obtendrás la respuesta de manera muy
rápida ahora en lo personal no me gusta
memorizar las cosas sin saber antes de
dónde vienen porque tal vez me topé con
algún problema en un futuro y si en un
acuerdo que voy a hacer así que mejor
aprendo a hacer las pruebas ahora en fin
esta fue la ley de los cosenos
utilizas y podrás resolver muchos
problemas con mucha más agilidad
simplemente acomodas el triángulo luego
sustituye y bueno en este caso
resolvimos para para el lado a así que
nos vemos en el próximo vídeo bain